bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors avec ses
résultats peut-on dire qu'alassane
ouattara consolide son pouvoir
après une réélection qui avait été testé
l'année dernière oui le ps d'alassane
ouattara a conservé son pouvoir
jusque là le rhdp le parti présidentiel
est à considérer un peu comme un parti
régionaliste sympathie dans le bastion
serait exclusivement le nord de la côte
doit la gagner de précieuses voix dans
le sud vers l'ouest dans l'est et dans
le centre ce qui donne une assise
vraiment nationale au rhdp donc le
président ouattara même de consolider
son pouvoir aller se donner la
légitimité qui lui manquait en soi du
temps seul entendre doublement c'est
aussi le grand retour du fbi le front
populaire ivoirien de laurent gbagbo est
ce qu'on peut dire que l'opposition
vient rééquilibrer les forces
même si elle n'est pas parvenue à
obtenir une majorité
oui à l'état que l'actualité inclusive
toutes les forces vives tous les grands
partis ont participé à cette élection
donc à l'essor de l'équilibrage
l'adhésion l'opposition toutes tendances
confondues s'en sort avec 4 sièges sur
les 254 ce qui n'est pas forcément
mauvais même si je me dis que
l'opposition peine un peu plus que ça
équilibre tant soit peu la fosse au sein
de l'assemblée nationale lors des débats
contradictoires
l'assemblée nationale ne plus me seule
couleur pas de violence pendant ce
scrutin contrairement à ce qui s'était
passé il ya quatre mois pendant la
l'élection présidentielle comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer début janvier il y
avait des lots politique dirigée par
minni ce que nos copains du côté du
berlais donc
pendant ce dialogue politique toutes les
tendances tous deux partis politiques y
ont participé et conseiller le président
henri konan bédié le fpi monsieur
laurent gbagbo
donc à partir chez au moins y'a plus
qu'à raison que la violence ne valent de
production a compris que j'allais
participer aux jeux politiques les
acteurs collectifs ont compris que
compétitivité les politiques ne citez
pas forcément là je lance comme vous le
disais nous organiser la première action
de 1995 en violences politiques malgré
tout le pouvoir et l'opposition avaient
revendiqué la victoire dimanche
alors est ce qu'on peut craindre quand
même que cela puisse mener à des
tensions dans le pays on sait que la
côte d'ivoire a été marquée par des
violences post-électorales auparavant
bon je ne pense pas c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu quelques députés qu'en fait quelques
confidences de passe quelques candidats
notamment à yamoussoukro mobile mais ils
ont décidé qu avant des saisies les
institutions électeurs à ses partisans à
la cij est une institution quelconque
aujourd'hui chacun beaucoup aux
institutions a chargé d'organiser les
élections c'est une bonne chose
on a un taux de participation qui
s'élève à 38% pour vous est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour un scrutin qui
nationalise certains mais un peu plus un
taux un peu plus élevé en 2016 17 à 34 %
s'attendent à ce que le temps plus une
un peu mais bon ça va 38% dans
moins d'un an sur les gens j'ai
d'ailleurs l'un de mes scores aux
élections législatives encore une loi ou
les initiatives autour de 30 ou 100 avec
donc ces résultats ces élections qui se
sont déroulées sans violence est ce
qu'on peut estimer qu'on va bien vers
une réconciliation nationale un tel que
le veut le souhaite le chef de l'état la
salle 2 mais là encore la question du
moon et charles blé goudé qui lui est
inconnu
déchaînant talent que je pense que nous
sommes sur la bonne voie
le retour du président charles blé goudé
pour consolider ses trois buts d'argent
olympique pacifique
oui le retour de laurent gbagbo ça
marquerait vraiment pour vous cette
réconciliation nationale pas seulement
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
sylvie sylvain par boeing et son je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique merci à vous